David Field is like many in America these days.
He resolved to pay off debt and get in better financial shape.
But unlike most of us, he didn't just talk about it, he actually did it.
In total, altogether in debt, I was about $18,000 and now, I'm down to 6,000.
How did he do this?
Well, he went to a credit counseling agency.
I called them up...
...when he said, "Yeah, we can get you out in this amount of time," you know,...
...he said about three and a half years, four years,...
...and I was like, "That sounds fantastic to me!"
In fact, it sounded so good that he decided to spread the message.
He's now working as a counselor at the same agency that helped him.
These agencies can create a plan that puts them between you and your creditors,...
...or if all you need is a little advice, they can help with that too.
Use cash.
Stop using their credit cards.
There's no way you're ever gonna get out of debt if you don't stop using those plastic things.
Simple advice that would keep you from racking up new debt this year.
And to eliminate the debt you already have,...
...for that, you may need a plan.
One that helps you find extra money that you can use to target debts for payoff.
You have to do some soul-searching...
...in order to design a plan that you're gonna stick to that will eliminate your debt.
Bottom line, if you resolved to pay off some debt this year,...
...stop talking the talk, start walking the walk!
Cut up the cards, track your expenses.
And if you need some help, find it.
For Money Talks, I'm Stacy Johnson.